so when you fought that kid you you
walked out to a six nine track do you
what was that that that that's kind of a
controversial i tell it don't do it uh
yeah i do i think his music's good i
like it
i remember it because because i wasn't
even sure i was like is this six nine i
believed that a lot it's hard to tell it
was like
i'm gonna be there at this next one ufc
369. six nine's gonna be there i went
out with them right after the fight um i
saw you you caught some [ __ ] because you
had him
tattooing six nine on you oh yeah i did
get a lot of [ __ ] for that um yeah i
never like growing up i've never really
i mean i guess you care what people
think in high school you're [ __ ]
insecure and everything but i i care
what people think man i get very
sensitive i do but i don't it's like a
weird like especially the more popular i
get and the more for whatever reason
money you get it's like you can give
less less [ __ ] like right i don't i
mean i did get a lot of heat from that
but then i still posted another picture
with them after and then like the
comments are the same [ __ ] like what are
you like what are you doing blah blah
blah but i'm not really doing things
just to please people
sure and i have no doubt that 69 is an
absolute sweetheart you know like
i'm good buddies with steve will do it
and uh those two are always hanging out
together and and uh
steve will do it says nothing but just
the nicest things about him all the time
yeah i've still never met him but uh
well you'll be at two you see 269 right
you gotta be i you know what like dude
i'm on tour man i'm on this bus going
everywhere
should have scheduled it in vegas what's
that what's the date two six nine
december 11 number 11 yeah massive steve
six the boys gonna be there the elk boys
are coming out i'm bringing out all the
all the celebrities and i'm i'm still
unranked i'm i'm still on the
pay-per-views i'll probably never not be
on a pay-per-view yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude